[Musique]
ça fait toujours un drôle d'effet je
n'arrive pas à m'habituer s'asseoir dans
un avion comme en corée dans un bus et
en quelques heures
traverser la planète de bout en bout
presque trop facile de jouer les grands
voyageurs à ce tarif là et en
contemplant le monde défiler sous mon
hublot envie de retrouver le goût du
voyage véritable authentique de revenir
à des choses simples
le voyage et terre à terre et surtout
façon locale
roy
new delhi 20 millions d'habitants comme
à mon habitude je n'ai rien vraiment
organisé pour ce voyage pas d'itinéraire
ni de but précis juste partir au plus
vite sur les routes vite me mettre en
quête d'un véhicule approprié et pour ça
j'ai ma petite idée
l'ambassadeur un pur vestiges des années
50 une vieille anglaise devenue au fil
des décennies taxis officiels et symbole
national
je saute dans le premier taxi pour en
savoir un peu plus sur elle
c'est pour être honnête
je n'ai jamais eu aucun problème avec la
boîte lui mais c'est un très bon outil
de travail
problème c'est plutôt le trafic
c'est très dur de travailler dans ces
produits
ça fait 15 ans elle et moi on connaît la
ville par coeur
elle marche vraiment très bien j'en ai
eu trois comme ça l'ambassadeur vont
encore survivre longtemps surtout que
maintenant les étrangers l'ont remarqué
et il aime beaucoup
introduit de nouveaux taxis dans la
ville des voitures modernes mais les
gens ont continué les préférées
l'ambassadeur et elle est bien plus
confortable
ils s'y sont bien gras et les touristes
quand il arrivait qu'il la voit ils
veulent absolument montée de l'or
- si on m'a proposé de l'échanger contre
attaque si moderne et même contre une
voiture neuve
je crois que je n'en voudrai pas je
garderai celle là en fait je
n'échangerais pour rien au monde
mon chauffeur me laisse entendre que je
pourrais trouver facilement une
ambassade or à mon goût dans un petit
garage des environs mais sur le chemin
et comme ça se fait souvent sans
demander l'avis du client une petite
poster qui va pouvoir retrouver en coin
5 minutes 10 il ya plein de garage on va
voir un bon thé
il ya beaucoup de moi
l'étranger est à la recherche d'une
ambassade or je suis pour trouver une
une ambassade à quillan bouge sans doute
là bas
acheter ou à louer dans le rajasthan
avec sa voiture va faire une grande
distance il se demande si c'est bien
pour lui bien sûr j'adore c'est ce qu'il
ya de plus solide
c'est très bien pour voiliers
à première vue le quartier des garages
ressemble plus à une vaste casse
disposer sur le bord de la route
le bruit court immédiatement dans le
quartier qu'un étranger est à la
recherche d'une ambassade or on vient
tout de suite me chercher pour me
présenter
voici la voiture une ambassador's belle
histoire quand vous voyez comme elle a
l'air solide hommes voulaient voir
l'interview à la fois moderne et ancien
nantais d'origine
c'est du métal et ça c'est le bruit
c'est la voie du moteur très costaud
vous aimez 7 milliards oui c'est un très
joli son c'est une voiture très lourde
et le moteur sévère estime pas les
mécaniques
c'est un moteur très simple c'est facile
à réparer drogue
allez si vous avez le moindre problème
c'est très facile de le résoudre et
fabrication indienne
c'est du costaud et vous trouverez de
quoi la réparer ou combien mais même
dans les plus petits villages
[Musique]
je peux te la faire à 3000 roupies
c'est vraiment pas cher et si je voulais
l'acheter vous me la banderille et je
vous la vend pas elle n'est pas à vendre
je peux juste vous l'avez vous voulez
lagarde et lui jouent là lourd mais je
vous l'avons pas mais je dois vous la
rendre vraiment
[Musique]
pour le même prix soit moins de 60 euros
j'ai même pu négocier une ambassador un
peu moins rustique il ambassador to
confort et toute option prise en main du
véhicule au volant ce qui s'impose c'est
malgré tout sa grande simplicité pas de
direction assistée par d'électronique
l'impression de revenir à l'essence même
de l'automobile
la difficulté il ya plutôt du dehors
pendant des heures je longe des
bidonvilles et des chantiers la ville ne
cesse de s'étendre et ne semble jamais
finir
salut
[Musique]
décidément la route indienne ne s'offre
pas facilement le moment de l'échappée
belle est toujours un peu plus repoussé
cette fois la circulation est
complètement à l'arrêt les gens ont
abandonné leur véhicule et investissent
la chaussée personne ne semble savoir ce
qui se passe et moi encore moins
trois heures ça fait 3 heures que je
suis ici c'est complètement bloquée
c'est pas vraiment ce qui se passe là
bas devant c'est peut-être un accident
d'autres disent une manifestation je
n'ai pas été voir ce qui est sûr c'est
que quand c'est comme ça faut être
patient c'est la seule fois qu'il y ait
ce genre de problème
tout le monde est pénalisé les clients
carte du temps et moi je perds du temps
et en plus je perds aussi de l'argent
surtout que ça peut durer encore
longtemps comme ça personne ne peut dire
c'est vraiment une très mauvaise journée
si tu veux te sortir de là s'il faut
faire demi tour et prendre la petite
route tu passes par la campagne on ne
veut pas des jeux
on ne veut pas de l'organisation des
jeux chine et nous vaincrons il faut
qu'il rende nos terres si nous les
prennent qu'est ce qu'on va devenir
il ne nous restera rien la terre c'est
notre travail c'est notre vie c'est
grâce à elle qu'on nourrit nos familles
alors moi je passe le message il ne faut
pas qu'ils nous prennent nos terres si
on nous les prend on sera condamnée à la
misère
c'est à cause des jeux tout ça sans
gagner à mai
[Musique]
tout finit par arriver je n'y croyais
plus enfin une petite route de campagne
enfin la voie est libre
[Musique]
la ville de jaipur et distante de
quelque 200 kilomètres je doute de
pouvoir y arriver avant la nuit et je me
demande si les indications qu'on m'a
donnée sont bonnes mais au fond peu
importe
[Musique]
la route ne cesse de se rétrécir et
s'enfoncent toujours un peu plus dans la
campagne en traversant les petits
villages
j'ai la vision d'une âme rural et
paisible d'une inde hors du temps le
bruit la poussière de délits me
paraissent déjà loin et c'est en
demandant son chemin que l'on fait
souvent les bonnes rondes seront ici on
vit en famille
il y à toutes les générations lorsque
les enfants ont fini leurs études ils
reviennent au village car ils n'ont pas
de travail et ils reviennent pour
travailler dans les champs avec les
parents on voit les hôtes et on est
heureux ici avant la vie à la campagne
était plus difficile
on manquait tout a commencé par le
maintenant on a installé un système
d'irrigation et du coup on arrive à
faire pousser mal de choses dans ses
champs tout comme mme aubry mais on ne
voit jamais l'étranger comme toi ici et
j'en passe juste à côté sur la route
mais il ne s'arrête pas là et nous
resitue accepte de rester chez nous ce
soir et de partager notre ligne
[Musique]
sans doute pour honorer ma présence fait
inhabituel les femmes et des enfants
participent aussi au dîner et khadija
même invité le maire du village à se
joindre à nous il n'ya jamais dos à la
pause ça ne marche pas c'est parce que
tu ne sais pas t'en servir et il n'y a
pas de lumière dans la rue c'est pas de
ma faute à moi mais tu es le
représentant des autorités
je n'y peux rien si vous donne pas
d'argent pour le faire si on ne donne
pas les moyens
je ne peux pas vous aider je suis comme
vous alors il faut que tu ailles les
voir et que tu leur demandes
ces tombeaux vas-y donc toi et amène ta
fille qui parle si bien là où je devais
avoir travaillé à l'école on verra plus
tard
il avait promis je n'aurais même pas de
quoi se payer un appartement qu'on a
voté pour toi tu n'écoutes plus nos
demandes tu t'en fiches
[Musique]
d'endettement
c'est la coutume ont coulé
au petit matin je reprends ma route
direction jaipur
le paysage est monotone l'air chargé de
poussières
la route indienne c'est un exercice très
particulier
ou plutôt un jeu dangereux au volant pas
le temps de s'ennuyer
ici pas de code de la route pas de règle
si ce n'est klaxonnaient klaxonnaient
encore et toujours pour ce ordinaire le
reste semble se faire tout seul avec
l'aide des dieux
bien sûr
[Musique]
zombies
m
[Musique]
jaipur avec ses innombrables pas laisser
immense bazar la cité princière
concentre tout l'exotisme du rajasthan
célébré pour la couleur rose saumon qui
couvre ses façades jaipur a été ainsi
entièrement repeinte en quelques jours
de 1876 à l'occasion de la visite du
prince de galles
mais en entrant dans la cité je suis
surtout de nouveau confronté au chaos de
ses embouteillages au concert des
klaxons et aux effluves de gaz
d'échappement
et au lieu de prendre le temps de flâner
à travers ses marchés ses petites
ruelles suite à une fuite d'huile
je dois me mettre en quête d'un garage
dans les faubourgs de la ville c'est
beaucoup moins romantique mais de la
santé de mon ambassador dépend la suite
du voyage
les garages indien c'est un spectacle en
soi
ici on rafistole on recycle ont démonté
on remonte à l'infini des véhicules
souvent hors d'âge et ce n'est pas la
clientèle qui ment il me faut insister
et surtout distribuer quelques billets
pour espérer passer le jour même et à ce
tarif là c'est le patron lui même qui
vient finalement s'occuper de mon cas
m
sagor c'est une très bonne voiture et je
sais ce que je te dis car j'ai travaillé
à l'usiné pendant presque dix ans je
disais construites ces voitures si tu
veux je peux te montrer mon certificat
de voiliers si c'est la voiture des
ministres et si on s'en sert partout
comme taxi ce n'est pas par hasard
c'est bien que c'est la meilleur
ambassadeur
si tu en prends soin elle vivra bien
plus longtemps que avant de continuer
plus loin et faut que la rencontre de
jaïpur comme toutes les voitures neuves
et celles qui vont faire un grand voyage
tu doit la faire bénir par un prêtre du
temple on est vendredi et c'est le jour
où les gens amènent leur véhicule devant
le temple voiture ou moto neuve ou pas
il faut les faire bénir ses obligés
c'est sans doute un mélange de
superstition et curiosité qui me
poursuivent les recommandations du
mécanicien jaipur est aussi et surtout
une ville sacrée son grand temple est
l'un des plus fréquentés du rajasthan
j'ai l'impression de me retrouver dans
une grande kermesse plus que dans un
lieu de culte à l'heure de la prière
on se presse d'abord devant les échoppes
pour acheter des offrandes aux gants
ganesh une noix de coco ou quelques
biscuits suffiront le plus dur est
ensuite de pénétrer à l'intérieur du
temps le vendredi c'est toujours comme
ça il ya beaucoup d'attentes
[Musique]
mais peu importe la tente rien ne presse
la visite au temple
c'est pour tous les hindous le moment
fort de la semaine on y passera
volontiers la journée le chemin est long
jusqu'à la statue du dieu disposé au
fond de la vaste salle et jusqu aux
prêtres chargés de réceptionner les
offrandes
[Musique]
m
à l'extérieur les véhicules en tout
genre ont pris place dans la file
d'attenté pour recevoir la cuggia la
bénédiction des yeux fatigués par un
prêtre spécialisé dans l'automobile et
qui semblent débordés par la demande il
appose sur les carrosseries flambant
neuf le symbole du dieu ganesh et un
collier de fleurs qui préviendront les
accidents et autres mésaventures sur la
route car en inde
même quand on est jeune et branchée on
n'en néglige pas pour autant la
tradition
la punjab c'est quand tu achètes quelque
chose de neuf qui le présente au dieu et
tu leur demande de venir ta moto mon ami
acheter une moto neuve et la première
chose qu'on a faite c'est de là mais
autant que pour la bénir ça permet de
prévenir les accidents
la macro du cannet c'est pourquoi on est
vu dans ce temple là c'est la culture
indienne c'est la tradition qui
nourrissent
[Musique]
et
celle là c'est la mienne mon tour est
enfin arrivé pas de traitement de faveur
comme les autres m'ont ambassador est
vite expédiée mais au moins j'ai
maintenant un véhicule bien assurée
[Musique]
oh
au delà de jaïpur gens entrent de plain
pied sur la terre des rois il n'y a pas
si longtemps 50 ans à peine les villages
que je traverse et elle est fiable des
seigneurs locaux qui régnait en maître
déchu de leurs privilèges à
l'indépendance les dernier maharadja
n'ont plus les moyens d'entretenir leur
luxuriant palais aujourd'hui laissés à
l'abandon
vestige d'une splendeur évanouie témoin
d'un autre monde pourtant pas si
éloignées
mais tout ne fut pas perdu leurs
descendants ont tout de même pu
conserver certains privilèges et
jouissent toujours d'une aura
particulière
rencontre avec un heureux héritiers
réputé dans la région pour être un
amateur de très belles mécaniques
za hadji ça c'est une jeep de 1956
l'armée indienne la prise à l'armée
pakistanaise pendant la guerre l'armée
indienne est utilisé à son tour elle
s'en est débarrassé et l'a mis à la
casse c'est alors que ma famille n'a
récupéré
on arrive chez moi et c'est ici que je
conserve mes côtés j'aime les concerts
avaient tout près de moi contre mon
coeur alors je vais te le présenter
ce sont mes bottés je commence avec
celle ci c'est une de mes préférées
elle fait encore du 160 à l'heure c'est
un modèle de 1961
je les ai achetés auprès d'une actrice
indienne très célèbre de la ville
et voici une dodge tonus doornbos cette
voiture était très apprécié des grands
marins indiens deux ils utilisaient pour
partir à la chasse au tigre avant
qu'elle ne soit remplacé par gueye mais
celle là on la trouvait l'état d'épave
abandonné sur un terrain vague
mon père l'a vu il a d'abord dit que
l'on ne pourrait rien en faire elle
était en trop mauvais état mais à côté
de la carcasse on a trouvé une boîte qui
contenait toutes les pièces d'origine
les phares la calandre l'emblème comme
alors là on s'est dit qu'on allait
peut-être savoir faire quelque chose
celle-ci tibi de l'époque d'elvis
presley une deux photos de 1954
celle là aussi c'est une véritable épave
craie être refondu pour en faire du
métal ça nous a pris cinq années pour la
remettre en état
et maintenant regardez la elle est
magnifique les années 1930 le monde a
connu une grande crise économique et les
seules personnes qui avaient de l'argent
à gaspiller à cette période c'était les
maharadjahs indien alors ils achetaient
des voitures de luxe en grande quantité
à tel point que les constructeurs
américains anglais et européen mais
condé directement de ces barrages qui
étaient les seuls à pouvoir les acheter
ce type de voitures ont donc débarqué en
grand nombre dans le pays pendant la
crise
dial mais après l'indépendance en 1950
des maharadjahs ont tout à coup perdu
leur titre et leurs privilèges
ils se sont retrouvés avec ses voitures
sur les bras sans les moyens d
entretenir maison alors vendu pour la
casse en quelques années l'inde a vu
disparaître toutes ces voitures de
prestige elles ont été jetés au rebut
comme de vulgaire tas de tôles vendues
au poids dans des casses
[Musique]
m
les messieurs le maharadja m'invite à
venir découvrir son nouveau chantier
il m'a promis que ça devrait
particulièrement intéresser direction le
palais de ses aïeux transformé en hôtel
de luxe
en tant que légitime directeur de
l'établissement il y héberge
gratuitement une cliente bien
particulière
[Musique]
voici une bande sonore l'ancêtre de
notre london ambassador que l'on utilise
toujours beaucoup en inde là où
aujourd'hui ambassador est une voiture
100 % 1 viennent elle a du mal à
survivre
elle a du mal parce que les indiens la
trouve trop vieille pas à ces pratiques
il ya beaucoup de poussière qui rentre
dans l'habitacle quand on roule et bien
qu'elle ait toujours ce charme
particulier à nos yeux elle n'est plus
adapté pour une utilisation quotidienne
ils ont essayé de la moderniser en lui
apportant un nouveau moteur une nouvelle
boîte de vitesses des caractéristiques
actuelles et son design est de toute
façon trop ancien pour qu'elle puisse
continuer aujourd'hui et comme cela les
indiens sont à la recherche de choses
très anciennes ou alors très moderne et
malheureusement l'ambassadeur se trouve
exactement entre les deux alors c'est
inévitable tôt ou tard elle va mourir
[Musique]
triste présage pour une voiture que l'on
aurait volontiers creux éternelle à en
croire le prince héritier philosophe de
la mécanique à 16h label ambassadeur
serait déjà en sursis
relégué au rang des indésirables des
ringarde au sont réguliers de son moteur
c'est comme une bonne vieille grand-mère
qui nous raconterait des histoires du
passé les souvenirs d'une inde qui
n'existe déjà plus la nuit tombe vite le
ciel se charge de nuages noirs
la campagne est endormi la route est à
moi ça
et
[Musique]
on
le jour se lève sur le lac d'udaipur la
cité se reflète sur l'eau comme dans un
miroir et la vie des habitants est tout
entière tournée vers leurs lacs udaipur
c'est la ville romantique par excellence
ici on aime à l'appeler la venise
indienne pour la première fois de ce
voyage l'arrivée dans une grande ville
me repose m'inspire calme et sérénité
une atmosphère unique règne ici on
comprend pourquoi
selon la légende c'est sur ces quais que
le dieu shiva il y à quelques deux mille
ans inventa le yoga
[Musique]
bon
non
l'entente l'eau est bonne
oui elle est très chaude tu vas aller de
beignets pour moi oui peut-être plus
tard les touristes se baignent dans
cette eau là
ces derniers temps par l'eau vient juste
de revenir
depuis cinq ans on n'avait pas eu d'eau
ici alors qu'on commence juste à en
profiter
si tu étais venu il ya un mois tu
n'aurais pas vu d'eau aussi les gens
marchaient dans le lit du lac
c'était complètement vide yahia et on
appelle de bonnes pluies ces dernières
années presque pas une goutte depuis
2000 les grèves de côté toute la ville
célèbre le retour de l'eau c'est une
grande fête
les dieux nous ont redonné de la ville
comme l'eau est particulièrement
importante pour udaipur la même façon
qu'un désert sans sable n'est pas un
désert sans son lac la ville n'est plus
la même elle ressemble à un désert
j'apprends que je ne suis pas tombé sur
le premier league est venu ni tine est
un maître réputé dans tout le pays et au
delà
nombreux sont les indiens et même les
occidentaux qui viennent de loin pour
suivre ses enseignements dans le yoga il
ya en tout 84 position et en fonction de
notre âge de notre sexe il faut chercher
quelles sont les positions qui nous
correspondent et ici en s'entraînant
chacun doit trouver quelles sont les
bonnes positions pour lui la seule
méthode pour apprendre le yoga c'est de
s'entraîner et de s'entraîner encore et
après cinq ou six jours seulement vous
pourrez déjà voir la différence
vous pourrez sentir l'énergie qui se
libèrent et se répand dans votre corps
et vous vous sentiez l'a déjà mieux
[Musique]
oh
une série que l'étincelle gobain
excellent temps pour vrai malgré son
aimable invitation à m'initier au yoga
je n'insiste pas la suite du court
trop impatient de partir découvrir la
ville en remontant les petites rues je
perçois une rumeur qui semble se
rapprocher et surtout arriver de toute
part en un instant je me retrouve
subitement plongé au beau milieu d'une
foule bruyante et colorée différentes
processions sont en train de converger
devant un temple
je n'ai pas d'autre choix que de me
laisser porter moi aussi par la foulée
par les chants de me laisser envahir par
ce spectacle flamboyant par cette
atmosphère irréelle
en cette fin d'été c'est la ville tout
entière qui est en train de célébrer le
retour de la pluie on avant que les
dieux pour leur générosité leur clémence
udaipur vivra dès lors au rythme des
chants des fêtes et des rituels qui se
mêleront jour et nuit pendant plus d'un
mois
[Musique]
au matin la vie semble avoir repris son
cours normal ou presque car udaipur ne
ressemble à aucune autre
le spectacle qu'offrent ces rues c'est
bien l'un d'eux comme on se l'imaginent
et même au delà
blur et pourtant au départ
[Musique]
mais en sortant de la ville mon regard
est attiré par une garde de vieilles
carcasses d'ambassadeur disposait sur le
bord de la route
ma curiosité me pousse à m'arrêter à
première vue ça ressemble bien à une
casse mais le propriétaire des lieux
réserve à ses quelques bouts de tôle un
tout autre destin
là ce sont des morceaux d'un modèle de
1962 voici le volant c'était le klaxon
ici le clignotant et enfin la boîte de
vitesses qui étaient intégrés
voici un pare-chocs ce type de pièces ne
sont plus du tout utilisé aujourd'hui
maintenant il se fait en mauvais
matériaux ceux là sont entièrement en
métal est il retient et n'a pas été
affecté en petits morceaux
c'est très compliqué de trouver les
bonnes pièces très compliqué de bien les
restaurer mais c'est un peu comme un
grand puzzle pour moi ça fait dix ans
que je fais ça et j'arrive maintenant
reconstituer les voitures en deux ou
trois mois mais c'est pas facile pour
les végétaux
cet amateur de puzzle a insisté pour me
montrer le garage où me dit il il fait
des miracles alors que je croyais avoir
déjà laissé udaipur derrière moi nous
voilà de retour vers le centre-ville
quand je suis au volant de cette voiture
je suis heureux je suis confortable je
suis en sécurité dans cette voiture je
me sens comme dans ma maison
je suis fier d'être un indien
c'est pourquoi je conduis une voiture
indienne je ne vois pas pourquoi je
conduirai une voiture construite dans un
autre pays
moi j'aime les voitures indiennes les
nouvelles générations ne veulent pas de
cette voiture
ils ne veulent même pas s'asseoir dedans
pour eux c'est une poubelle se fiche du
confort et de la sécurité qu'offre cette
voiture ce qui les intéresse c'est de
conduire vite pourquoi ils veulent aller
vite ça je ne sais pas et c'est pour ça
que petit à petit ça va en être fini de
l'ambassador c'est pour ça que moi je
les collectionne maintenant je créerai
un musée de l'ambassador mais en
attendant le musée le made in il ya un
peu vintage à quatre roues ou même 2
reste un bon business auprès des jeunes
traveller occidentaux et branché je
crois que j'ai perdu une pièce elle fait
un bruit bizarre quelque chose est parti
et il faut remplacer cette pièce
coûterait combien j
2000 pour la pièce et après il faut voir
peut-être que je dois tout démonter
disons tout compris dans les 2500 euro
ppi 2005 sens c'est beaucoup et c'est ce
que je vais mettre moi-même dans la
réparation combalié falloir installer le
moteur d'abord il faut tout bien
préparés à l'intérieur
sinon tu vas être embêté faut que ce
soit bien propre à l'intérieur un
d'accord alors celle là il faut tout
faire
tu vas mettre un grand tapis wen noir
c'est le mieux les auris et l'ida
d'accord et au plafond tu mets du tissu
là non c'est important mais du tissu la
même couleur que le tapis et fabrice
tourre si tu veux que je te restaure une
voiture en parfait état comme la tienne
et que je te l'envoie en france il faut
compter que 420 1000 roupies et vous me
feriez un petit prix non je ne baisse
pas le prix ni d'un héros ni d'un groupe
i le prix c'est le prix alizée c'est ce
que moi
[Musique]
je n'ai pas cédé à la tentation même
pour un peu moins de 3000 euros
que faire d'une ambassadeurs en france
et à la maison elle n'aurait sans doute
pas la même saveur
cap à l'est plus de 300 kilomètres
séparent udaipur de jobs pour ma
prochaine étape à 60 km heure de moyenne
sur des routes le plus souvent très
mauvais état la journée promet d'être
longue
et à ce rythme là la meilleure manière
de s'occuper reste de savourer chaque
kilomètre
surtout ne pas se presser ne pas la
brusquer se détendre et puis bien sûr
profiter
[Musique]
excuse mais ça excusez moi monsieur
j'avais jobboom
et malheureusement j'ai raté bruce tu
veux venir avec moi oui oui ok allez
rentrer merci monsieur d'où est ce que
vous venez monsieur je viens de france
ou par les français ah bah oui moi je
prends français mais tout aussi tu parle
français
avg l'appui un policier
reproduit celle conduite ou sa capture
ou la passion vraiment c'est pas facile
pour vous parce que le loot indiens se
sont quelque peu le problème étrangères
qui connaît pas bien
le lot 2
hélène
parce que toutes les journées on
votre toutes les familles aux transports
mouloud
les voitures et bien
de l'action
actionnaires mais vraiment toutes ses
interviews
parce que comme une insulte
kodama
sinon
c'est moi
il klaxonne amicitia défense de l'ol
pourrait en tout le monde
de l'autre c'est ça
[Musique]
à l'occasion d'une petite posté sur la
route
mon passage et en profite pour me parler
un peu de son pays et de ce que c'est
que d'avoir 20 ans ici et les cultures
des langues
je sais pas non j'ai du mal à comprendre
2 c'est très complexe et vie mais c'est
très compliqué pour nous parce que le
système de castes cette distance
je préfère les changer de culture
je préfère le modem l'écriture moderne
c'est comme ça que les gens parlent avec
les filles c'est ça les cultures
modernes
on peut travailler dans leurs bureaux
ensemble avec le fis et les gens c'est
ça elle sait aussi que si on préfère les
filles pour choisi son mari c'est aussi
les cultures modernes pour moi aussi on
doit la caisse qui se passe
[Musique]
voici le nouveau plongé dans la
circulation chaotique d'une grande ville
en arrivant à jodhpur je remarque que
j'avais déjà presque oublié le ballet
ininterrompu des rich cho et des deux
roues le concert incessant des klaxons
j'ai laissé vie qui m'ont passagers à
l'entrée de la vie nous nous sommes
donné rendez vous pour le lendemain
matin il veut m'emmener quelque part
avant que je reprenne la route
pour l'instant j'essaie de me frayer un
passage de long des rues jusqu'à la
première auberge les journées de route
comme celles ci sont épuisantes
[Musique]
au matin jeux de sport dévoile son
visage
témoin de la splendeur passée de la
domination sans partage des maharaja sur
la cité le fort de jodhpur domina ville
qui se déploie à ses pieds et après la
ville rose voici la ville bleue les
maisons anciennes sont un temps d'indigo
couleurs des dieux comme prévu j'ai
retrouvé vie qui est nous sautons dans
un rickshaw direction les hauteurs de la
ville
[Musique]
monde
debout en décider regarde c'est lui sur
la ville tu peux facilement imaginer la
magnificence des rois du rajasthan tu as
tu vois que la ville est encerclée par
l'effort et les châteaux de maintenant
regarde les maisons peintes en bleu
elles sont réservées à une caste
spéciale les bras mines
ce sont des crêpes et si le casque la
couleur bleue qui recouvre les maisons
est une manière de célébrer le dieu
shiva le bleu et sa couleur mais il ya
une autre version pour cela l'autre
raison c'est que la couleur bleue est
connu aussi pour son pouvoir de
repousser les moustiques hip hop et dans
mon choix
c'est un mélange de l'aspect à la fois
spirituelle et pratique des choses look
de regarde par la peau de l'est de la
ville
c'est le désert qui commence c'est leur
part là-bas le désert n'est plus très
loin
[Musique]
alors bonjour monsieur comment ça va
hein pas une scène qui va bien merci et
vous ça va ailleurs valu temps j'ai un
petit problème avec ma voiture
vous voulez un peu dingue je peux je
t'aime mais si vous voulez on peut
regarder ça ensemble
vraiment c'est à première vue c'est
peut-être que le moteur a eu chaud il
faut attendre que ça refroidisse
on va déjà aidé avec de l'eau est-ce que
voilà on va bien arrosées avec de l'eau
est comme ça ça va faire partir la
vapeur qui bloque les tuyaux ça arrive
souvent sur cette voiture
mais faut pas venir ici tout seul avec
cette voiture c'est pas prudent pour ses
caricatures qu'on sait qu'on peut
essayer de la démarrer oui on va
attendre un peu et on va essayer de le
faire repartir sur même la chance
je ne pense pas que ça va marcher comme
ça
c'est incroyable
ok merci beaucoup mais 5 et note
possible
on sait que je ne peux pas attendre la
ville avant la nuit tu as bendella plus
tard pour partir et vous ne connaissez
pas bien réagi
vous pouvez venir avec nous au
groupement 1 vous repartirez joker au
caire se joue ce week end est d'accord
je veux laisser la voiture ici the night
ah oui il s est passé la soirée n'en
vouliez vous dormez vous la reconnais de
l'insulté carbeo problème dans la
voiture d'accord et salle à ti barth
juillet comment vous voyez c'est ouvert
il a beaucoup plu cette année c'est très
bénéfique pour nous sans la pluie le
bétail meurt et nous aussi quand ça la
pluie le désert est devenu tout vert
l'herbe à poux c c'est vraiment
incroyable je n'ai jamais vu comme ça on
arrive même à faire pousser des
lentilles et du thé
[Musique]
nice est fort mais c'est encore loin
c'est plus très loin il faut passer les
dunes on est installé juste derrière
parce que c'est à l'abri du vent c'est
juste de l'autre côté
allez encore un petit effort et je vais
te montrer la vue qu'il ya là ok
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le désert du thar nous
sommes tout près du pakistan la
frontière n'est qu'à 120 km avant on
circuler librement dans l'ue
mais maintenant le désert est occupée
par l'armée alors on ne peut plus y
aller les causes de ce qui se passe
maintenant à la frontière alors on doit
rester ici mais ça va on est tranquille
la ville est difficile mais ça va
maintenant tu avec les photos la nuit
tombe il faut rejoindre paris la matière
e
on attendait
marino a les chars et les 1 500 onces et
rencontrés sur la route
c'était une belle expérience on a bien
discuté il avait un problème avec sa
voiture mais je les répare et je lui ai
proposé de venir avec nous pour manger
il roule en ambassador c'est rare de
voir ici des étrangers qui se déplace
seul avec cette sorte de voiture est
d'ailleurs à lui a posé un problème
un invité étranger en ambassadeurs
c'est la première fois qu'on voit ça
d'habitude ils viennent en groupe avec
des guides
c'est un honneur d'avoir quelqu'un qui
vient de moins c'est un plaisir tu as
notre respect yvinec tuyaux mais c'est
quelque chose claire
au matin bonne surprise la voiture était
toujours là mais au lieu d'un désert
c'est une tempête verdoyante que je
traverse une bénédiction des dieux que
cette pluie qui a transformé le paysage
mais je dois l'admettre une certaine
déception pour moi qui espérais de cette
dernière étape un dépaysement un peu
plus radicale
c'était donc ça le bout du monde
mais au fond peu importe peu importé
destination les buts à atteindre et des
lignes d'arrivée au volant de la brave
ambassador au sont réguliers de son
moteur en vitesse de croisière
ce qui compte c'est la route elle-même
kilomètre après kilomètre jour après
jour c'est elle qui nous offrent les
rencontres et les belles surprises qui
défait les clichés et les préjugés c'est
la route elle-même qui nous offre
l'essentiel
peu importe le flacon pourvu qu'il y ait
l'ivresse
bon
[Musique]
vous
m
[Musique]